[Music]
[Applause]
aute oh what a lad well as I try and do
every year on what a lad is to finish
the seasons with one of the all-time
great and here we are at the end of
season 4 with one of the very best he's
a white cuto and Chiefs Legend who's
played over 100 times for his beloved
franchise
while over the last eight years he has
been a very consistent name in The
Mighty All Blacks heading to two Rugby
World Cups and he's won plenty of
trophies along the way he's also someone
who's openly spoken about some of the
struggles that come along with being a
professional rugby player and he is the
ultimate lad it is of course the legend
himself Anton Lennard Brown welcome mate
Jimmy ma what intro thanks very much Pro
probably the best over had done few our
podcast in my time but you have yeah
appreciate the the kind words M well one
thing that I I did mention there but one
thing I have always tried to do on this
podcast is to get guys to open up and
share a little bit more than you usually
do but I feel like that's something that
you've always done I feel like you're a
bit of a Trailblazer for in that space
you've done it ever since I can remember
what do you think that is or how did you
get that yeah I guess in the in the
mental health space really passionate
with it about it and I think you know
early on in my career I went through
some some struggles like every
professional rugby player does or
everyone in life um but got to you know
a pretty dark dark stage that I've
spoken about probably between the age of
18 and 20 and sort of come out the other
side and um as I say as the old cliche
say is a stronger man and from there
I've been really passionate about
especially talking about mental health
so were you comfortable speaking about
your struggles and stuff from a young
age or was it just after that that you
felt I'm comfortable talking about this
I want to help others or
um it's no I've never been comfortable
about talking about it even if we and we
will like gone to death about it today
um it's never like a thing that comes
natural to me but it's more that I care
about other people and it's probably
that care that makes me want to talk
about it because I just want to share my
experience and hopefully at least one
person can be like oh I've had that as
well and they can relate I think that's
the beauty of why I've loved doing this
podcast as well cuz I get that feedback
after every episode of when people share
and open up and they're vulnerable how
much that helps it's crazy how many
people are going through something that
you wouldn't even think of and them
hearing especially superstars of the
game like yourself sharing um your
journey and what you've been through is
always so powerful so very cool thanks
BR but I'm looking forward to it cuz I
know all Journeys are um roller coasters
all everyone I've had on had some sort
of roller coaster ups and downs through
their um rugby career and I mean yours
is no different and even the latest
Rugby World Cup was no different for you
either really like you guys had your
highs your lows what do you remember
what's your memories of that Rugby World
Cup oh yeah man it you know it still
hurts um right now um but Man Memories
you know probably until about you know
right up until we lost it yeah memories
are awesome um
obviously you know I went over in 219
you know we were the favorites and
pretty much every old black team up
until that stage up until this year had
gone in as favorites people expect you
to win um so this one was a little bit
different um you know we went in with I
guess people doubting us people saying
they you know they won't get past the
quarterfinal type thing and yeah it was
just really cool it it brought us closer
as a team and man we had like some of my
best U moments as rugby player like
experiences you know just being around
the boys getting in tight and man it was
so fun and I think the other thing was
we're so far away from home that it just
felt like it was it was just us and the
family obviously we felt the support
back home but only on social media not
like by being around people so that's a
that's a different feeling yeah
obviously the first game was a massive
one against France um unreal atmosphere
looked incredible to be there um what do
you remember about that one yeah like I
just remember the buildup and it it look
it's the biggest opening game ever yeah
and um it's probably a little bit of a
shame that France went out um but yeah
like just the the atmosphere the the
hype around the game was it really was
the biggest game I've ever been a part
of the leader yeah jeez and then you
obviously had a few um I guess lesser
they weren't really lesser games you
made them lesser games especially like
the Italy game everyone was thinking it
could be like a type banan skin game but
man that was a game where you guys just
put on an absolute Clinic yeah like I
mean once we lost to France obviously we
got through Namibia and then like we
were really nervous for that Italy game
and all honesty like we we never well
you know you always when you're in the
black Jersey you always want to play
well but never before for myself and and
lot of other boys have we felt so
nervous playing Italian team we knew
that we had to win um and we knew
they're a good side and yeah to put out
a a performance like that was was pretty
special and sort of everything come
together yeah and you mentioned that in
the be a game talk to me about that try
one of the all time great Rob for of the
Year
sure oh
mate I've been going to um ever since I
started uh with the All Blacks and I get
[__] for it but I've been going to
kicking sessions every Tuesday oh yeah
Tuesday Thursday Friday and the reason
for it is cuz sort of my best mates are
D bod and Jordy and they're always there
so yeah I just like like a little kid
like you love just kicking the ball
around and kicking goals and stuff like
that so I just stay behind
and it's been a long time coming it's
probably my thir third ever kick in the
uh in the old blacks and I always say
eight years of practice there it was
worth every minute of the
K but you were you were playing a fair
bit of wing um in that Rugby World Cup
we comfortable out on the wing do you
enjoy playing on the wing
no man I this is in me me and doo
laughed after the game but well in in my
opinion and
like it just made sense for me to go
into the Midfield and probably push R to
the wing cuz I mean he he was the best
swinger in the world not too long ago
yeah um but the coaches had other ideas
and and obviously as a play just do do
as you're told yeah um but so in that
that Island game um B beron NOA he calls
up the the subs and he goes to me oh
Anton you go on the wing left wing
forista obviously the the game's tight
yeah and I go um no no we'll put r on
the wing
eh and he goes n mate you you're on the
wing I was like I was like brilliant and
and you like Wing rolls you got like
it's it's quite
complicated there's all these different
um roles and I was going on and we were
it was like they had a line out 5 m out
from the trail line yeah and it's a
different setup for a Winger as you'll
know all those rugby terms so I went on
and I think it was straight away it was
like a yellow card penalty
try um but anyways it ended up all
working out um it was yeah I think
Nuggie put up one high ball for me
haven't haven't tried to catch a high at
training and never and I missed it so
you're never expecting to go on as a
Winger no no basically it was like What
if it was a what if no I I knew that it
was a chance and
um and yeah I just ended up going on the
wing and then probably like in the in
fos and F's mind like he didn't want to
change too many people around which is
is fair enough and I guess D on the wing
is a little bit like D at Center so yeah
that's where like that's probably the
reason they put me on the wing was sort
of knowing how to D there yeah so and
that was that was some game that was I
think the best game I think I've ever
watched or footy that was just
incredible like we always confident or
what what are you what are you thinking
while you're out there in those
especially those last sort of dying
moments you honestly you get out there
and as you know Jimmy M like it's you
know when you sit on the bench like
that's when you have all your thoughts
yeah and then like I always say it's
easier to start the game because you're
just straight out there you're not
thinking but when you're sitting on the
bench you're thinking you're like holy
and then you're thinking well don't
Chuck me on the wing right now and they
do but you run out there and I think I
was out there for like 18 minutes or
something like that and it just it's all
a blur M you're out there just playing
footy and and everything was was all
right but yeah that
was yeah to to experience that one to be
to be out there and how they went 37
phases and all that stuff um and to sort
of be written off and I think in my
opinion Ireland were the best team in
the world but we always spoke about um
at Rugby World Cup it's not always the
best team in the world wins it's the
best team on the day MH and we just
nudged them out on the day they we were
just 1% better than them so that's how
tight World World Cups can be yeah it's
so true and then talk to me about the
final obviously um another game like
obviously so gathered about the loss but
you watch that and you just can't help
but feel really proud of the effort that
everyone put in in that performance like
you speak about 1% so that was like 0.1%
of that game like what do you remember
about that one um I remember going so
against all went on the left in South
Africa went on the right wing it was
another light mean mean moment but again
you get out there and and it's it's all
good um
but yeah it wasn't like it's it's hard
to digest mhm um but I think you know as
a as a rugby player or in most players
in the old blacks are experienced you
get really good with you know heartache
and obviously that's the Pinnacle
um but yeah I know I know it was tight
and I know odds was sort of stacked
against us and things didn't go away and
you know that's just rugby like Rugby's
not fair um and that to winning World
Cup you know you've doesn't matter what
happens you've got to overcome that and
you know unfortunately um we didn't but
yeah like straight after the game was
just was that
realization I think you know one of the
boys said it but you know when George
grean said four more years the infamous
saying like that's when you're like
well well hope you know hopefully all
going well it's four more years till you
get opportunity to to play for a World
Cup
and not only play for a World Cup like
doesn't guarantee that you'll be in the
same situation again cuz you know how
hard it is to get to a final and
yeah yeah it's um it was so close but
but so far
away so comparing that game like
obviously you've been to two Rugby World
Cups already comparing that loss of the
in the final compared to the one against
England in the semi-final how does that
compare like what's the what's the
difference thinking about it is probably
going out in the semi-final was easier
even though it
sucked but like losing losing a final
like really really hurts cuz you're
you're that step closer but the the
thing as well was England just
completely outplayed us M like we were
we were well and truly beat in that
semi-final whereas
in the final it was like you said it was
it was close we and still with what went
on like we still had opportunity
and um yeah I'd say those are the two
differences going out a final is is
harder and playing a game where you know
you could have won that that's harder as
well it's awesome Insight feel like I've
just come off the r c feel like I just
played there oh that's just my opinion
yeah yeah that's all that we care about
so one thing I always try to do is go
through the um whole journey from the
start I know you're a Christ Church boy
They Call You The One That Got Away
around here but talk to me about your um
upbringing here in Christ Church yeah I
grew up um next to the Rick and race
course maybe that's where I get my love
for for racing but um it actually wasn't
entire moved up north um until I I
started really getting into my my horse
racing but I grew up there which was
which was awesome we had a big backyard
and could pop over to the race course
and would play Touch there always walk
the dog and man that's that place has
changed like crazy um it just like a big
padic but now there's all these houses
down there and stuff but you obviously
have your older brother what was your
guys relationship growing up oh it was
it was good it was um a lot of fight
like a lot of a lot of competition um is
it just you too oh I got a we got a
older sister as well um so yeah
basically how it worked was Dan would
beat me up and then I would tell my
older sister yeah and she' beat Dan up
that was the cycle of life that um went
on in the household but I think like
for for a young boy especially like
having an older brother is awesome
because you want to do everything they
do and I think in a way like you get
opportunity to try harder or you get to
see what they do like you know when he
started playing rugby I think I started
playing rugby I was like young I was too
young to play but I still played because
I wanted to do what he did yeah so I
guess that always gave me the
opportunity to start start things
earlier M um but yeah we had
a we had an awesome upbringing like as
you can imagine big backyard we um two
like well we call them cousins but
they're family friends
um sort of same age Raymond T so they
they' be around every weekend we'll play
um two on two rugby in the backyard then
go inside knee rugby then play
Playstation we'll be playing Cricket
yeah and that's like I guess having a
having a a big brother like you get to
do those things yeah and then like when
you look back on it you know all those
games you play like it all adds up right
like it's all those I guess what they
call like 10,000 hours you as a kid of
just having fun yeah were you good like
from a young age no no I wasn't
well um i' yeah compared to other people
like um I wasn't like probably the best
example was I played at Maris albian
from under five with fonga and from 5
years old like obviously you don't have
a lot of memory but that guy's always
been a superstar oh yeah um and I was
back then I was actually playing prop oh
I was thinking 10 12
way back but prop yeah I was playing
prop from about 5 to to 13 were you you
and your brother yeah me and my brother
sort of played like prop prop hooker we
quite a big unit um went through stages
yeah you know like those kids stages
used to love eating um condensed milk
after school likeing that just a t of it
just a t of
it white bread and and chocolate chips
in the microwave so
put on put on put on a a few kigs and
then it'll get you
yeah um so yeah I was actually actually
a prop um so I guess when you say was I
good in terms of like what backs were
did I was actually playing prop yeah
yeah but I always dreamt of playing The
Backs you're a good prop yeah I I think
it's a good prop there you
go but then you dreamt of becoming a
back and then you somehow manifested
that to move to the backline yeah how
did that come about so less condensed
milk less
condens actually you know I went through
a a grow spirit and you know I was like
short chubby and then I sort of like thn
out MH um but how it come about was in
in year
12 and so my year n going to boys high
so in year 12 I stole a prop played kry
on 65s as a lucid prop or something like
that under
12s um and then the next year I went to
league and I was like well new sport I'm
just going to go play Cent oh true yes I
did uh one year at league for the
celebration lons managed to to thin out
a bit enjoyed at Center and I I come
back to boys high and just was like I'm
just going to play 12 yeah how'd you go
at
League um pretty good yeah actually
right made the the can sides and yeah
was it even option to play league not
not really like going to um Kish boys
high school um it wasn't wasn't really
an option but it was probably like a
pinnacle moment in my life
because like I sort of went to boys high
and then knew I'd played can be under
65s as a prop so if I played under nines
they would have KT me as a prop I went
to lucky I went to Le went to the back
so switch yeah obviously crushit boys
high as is a very well Renown rugby
school um what was it like for you being
in it oh it was it was like it's like
one of the you know some of the best
memories I've had um my my older cousin
or those cousins are talking about we
played rugby with all the time to he he
was playing first my first year I know
idea like what was what it was about or
like how many people went to games but
yeah and year I went to a beads at beads
St beads vers boy high and there's like
3,000 people there they had the
chainsaws going and all that all the
chance and I just remember thinking like
this is what I want to do this you know
I want to be in the first of one day
yeah so did you change anything like
were you TR were you training hard what
what were you doing to to make it did
you sit goals or was it just
pretty yeah I did probably like when I
got to year te
I set goals and I you remember I had a
book I don't know like it would have
been after
canb meeting or whatever someone come in
and said set goals so I'd set goals from
like it was like over 8ye period I think
I chucked the book out yeah but like
from memory almost every step I set my
goal at like I made it like yeah that's
crazy it's crazy how that works um so
yeah and then I've played a lot of
simens yeah um D would take us along to
like senior men s so I did that from 14
years old M and I started playing like
senior men sevens in year 12 so oh true
they also helped yeah and any games that
stand out um in your school boy days
obvious I think there was he you would
have been playing against Damian at
Christ and all those boys who Richie
would have been at Richie fliter Smith
um you they had three three gun true
yeah and in the same year did did you
guys win the comp we won the comp in my
year 1 year oh yeah yeah um but games
that I stuck out probably oh winning the
Press Cup against
beads that was pretty pretty special at
Rugby Park oh the memories yeah yeah
well let's go and then what was from
there somehow you end up in um W with
the Chiefs so what was did that
happen yeah um so it was before a
traditional game um and Mr Taylor called
him at the time he was a head Master of
the hostal
and he said or he called me in and he'd
coached me like in the under 14s and he
said uh after the game someone wants to
meet you I I'll take him to you I was
sweet as played played the game and so
Wayne Smith come down and watch a
traditional at Christ college and
actually he that's when he so he come
down to watch me and he also saw D at
the same time oh true but yeah so I
spoke to um to smth off the the game and
then he come around and and spoke to my
parents
and um he he talked about like where he
sees me at the Chiefs and said like he
look after us what she what she or look
after me what she does like he's a very
genuine man but that teacher Mr Taylor
he said you do whatever this man tells
you oh true so and I had a lot of lot of
respect from him so so he was at the
Chiefs at the time not the All Blacks he
was at the Chiefs yeah so I just pretty
much said I I'll do what SMY says and
ended up moving up up north and and the
next year D come up as well true and uh
James Tucker who was playing playing for
St beads yeah did they make a case for
you to stay here like obviously not many
people leave
the Crusader cany type Academy setups
but did they did they make a play for
you obviously they did but like probably
after
smth yes Chase made a made an offer and
and you and you're totally right um like
it was actually I think James Tucker Doo
and myself were actually like the first
guys to leave oh really like so G is a
different story because he like wasn't
really getting picked or like they
didn't want him here so he left but we
actually like three players that they
wanted around and and and we left up to
the Chiefs um but Smith's actually like
he was the one that started the scouting
system in can and the Crusaders and
that's how they ended up with so much
talent so you got the Grass Roots Talent
yeah but they're also pulling Talent
from all over the country so you know
like the the Sy it was it was hard to
beat the system here cuz you've got so
many good players and obviously the
cream r at the top but like you just the
pool they had to choose from was was
outstanding and so Smithy obviously
started it here it was really successful
then obviously went to the chase he's
like well I'm going to start doing it
back there yeah so he started pull
pulling Talent from all over the country
he's obviously got a really good eye for
talent too so that must have given you
heap of confidence as a young fellow
that knowing that Wayne Smith um a
legendary coach has has seen something
in you that um he's going to back and
trust and give you this sort of plan to
see where you're going to get to yeah
100% like you know probably when you
asked me before was I good like I worked
really hard at at school and like the
harder I worked the more opportunities I
got on I played better but I wasn't like
a naturally like talented Superstar like
for example like a like a rich moong who
obviously trains hard but in school days
he could you know his talent just got
got him through um so that was probably
the first time in my life you know
having someone like him saying oh we
want you up the Chiefs like I think
you're you're a really good player there
was like a shock for me like cuz even in
year 12 like I was starting but I wasn't
sort of a superstar then year 13 I was
having a really good year so it wasn't
like from under fives I'd been caring
out yeah it was really in this year 13
year having a really good year then way
Smith come by and yeah it was just I was
sort of God smacked yeah it's cool how
it can change so quickly he 40 like like
you said like one minute you're just a
average versus team player and then next
like two years later you're playing on
the win for the Chiefs in a debut game
hey like that all happen so fast for you
he
yeah it did um and my last game at
school I deated my shoulder so I went up
north
and I I just Tred to rehab it and then I
come back for club and I disate it again
so finished school and then my first
year up at the Chiefs or and while I
told I was I was injured for the whole
year so I missed missed the whole year
out how hard was that for you mentally
like everyone says like when they go to
a new environment especially as a young
fellow who's been backed by Wayne Smith
how hard is it to you for you to turn up
and not be able to show your worth yeah
it was um it was tough like cuz when you
move somewhere like you don't have the
credit like you know you like no one
knows you yeah like no one knows if
you're any good or not um so you're sort
of up there you can't play so how do you
prove yourself yeah um but we'd actually
and Y custle we had a really good
Academy and like we stuck
strong um but yeah I just had this like
mentality that that the only way I was
going to prove myself was to train real
hard so got through that like train did
all my rehab like trained real hard all
through that year didn't play any code
and that sort of gave me the opportunity
to be picked for the Chiefs wider
training group in two 24 true um and yes
I finished school a year year and a half
out and year and a half later I was
playing on the wing for my first
competition game yeah never played men
like no Club no NPC that's crazy yeah
and was it the balls over there yeah the
balls fck right so what an experience
for a young fell yeah yeah that's
probably where demons come from being on
the wing it's F when you when you ask on
the wing and the in the World
Cup just remembering the day did you go
no good trying to destroy
me was it D no good um it was right I
think your brother Tojo was playing oh I
think he was you guys would have had
some combo yeah I on the wing to um Tojo
was at
12 H wasn't wasn't my my best game yeah
um yeah there was
uh yeah we'll just leave it there did
you feel it out there like you said in
the World Cup like when you're out there
you're not really you're just in it but
I mean this is your first game against
man are you thinking are you
overthinking it while you're out on the
field in these moments or yeah I think
when you're when you're young and I'd
actually played a couple preseason games
and like like built my
confidence like played played pretty
good so I like oh sweet like I'm I'm
prepared for this and I think when
you're young like you know that game
like you need you need confidence and
the first two things I did like I think
I missed a tackle and like maybe dropped
the high ball or something and then like
you just go straight into your show
whereas like you know you score a try
and your first touch or something you're
just a away like you're 18 years old
yeah and you're you're so vulnerable
like the game can go either way yeah you
can either have a have an awesome game
or you going have shocker like there's
no real in between like you 18yearold on
on debut like you don't really expect
like a a mature just did his job
performance you either go oh yeah he's
going to score a hatrick or he's going
to get pulled off after 50 minutes and I
was pulled off after
50 yeah or then what are you feeling
after that game yeah like pretty pretty
down on the pretty down on the dumps and
um I was like 18 years old and obviously
growing up and and FY I thought the
whole world was watching like you think
that Rugby's like you know you think
Rugby's everything 100% it's not until
you gr grow a little bit older you like
oh like yeah soccer's way bigger than
you honestly think Rugby's yeah yeah so
oh man like I was on TV people think oh
[__] this guy's [__] like why do they
put on the
wing um but I think the hardest thing is
that like all the older guys guys you
look up to you want to like prove
yourself too and you know for a couple
days the I don't even want to look them
in the eye um cuz you just feel like you
you let them down yeah or felt like I
let them down and did you play the
following week or like yeah yeah I
played I played the following week um
Off the Bench oh yeah and I actually
like I was pretty for that that week
it's pretty down on the dumps and as you
know like that's footy like it's like
their day yeah and I think when you get
older like your emotions can can stay
still but early on like you're really
riding at if you you have a good game
like you you're walking around like yeah
if you have a bad game you're straight
into your shower so um yeah and that
week I was very much in my show yeah do
even want to catch rugby Bo like oh just
see me home going to bed like you know
you got all the all the stuff in your
mind yeah um but yeah went out the next
week
and I think we won in like the last
minute managed to get like a turnover
and in a break and and I was exactly
that went from what being 6 feet under
to 6 feet above the ground yeah crazy so
when you you obviously have had
throughout your career since heaps of
young guys come in and join your squad
you would have seen guys on debut have
moments like that what what do you do
what do you what's what's your actions
to
them yeah like I
always really like conscious of that
fact so that's like where my passion
around mental
health like is because I experienced
that young and then obviously I know
that young kids have that as well um so
it's more like during the week I try get
around them um just say like just be
yourself like do your thing and then
yeah depending on on how things go just
like get get around them for the game um
cuz yeah like and everyone's different I
know there's so many different
personalities in the game but like you
can just sometimes you're like say in
the gym and you know how things are
going like but you can just look at
people and see like they're thinking
about something you know someone might
have made a mistake in the weekend you
get to Monday gym you they just staring
at the wall it's
like yeah just just you know just go
over and and have a yarn
how's it going and it's not like going
over the top but just being conscious of
it and and just you know just talking to
them yeah I like that you obviously got
through it pretty quickly because I
think it was what two years after your
debut you you're named as an all black
so that's another a massive rise
there yeah um I was actually well yeah
debuted at 18 so it was in my third
season for for the Chiefs yeah got yeah
got named
um yeah on the for the old blacks in 216
which was yeah like oh just unbelievable
and yeah sort of like all through like
my career well when I got the
opportunity for the Chiefs and then
opportunity for the the ABS you know I
felt as though
like I wasn't like a superstar or like
you know I wasn't really like knocking
on the door but it sort of happened um
and and in all all fairness like how I
got the opportunity was about five
midfielders got injured oh true and that
well yeah I think Sunny um George Mara
got injured which got me into the squad
and then Ryan Cy got injured which gave
me at a start oh yeah um so got
fortunate um I guess through through the
um the bad luck
but um in the same way like I really
felt
when I got named for the All Blacks
that it was like being 18 years old
again you know on the wing like I felt
as like we never got on my opportunity
like it's just been like through
injuries out of the blue like I haven't
really built into this yeah it's just
happening um but the one promise I made
to myself was that I went into my
sh as a 18yar old and that's all I said
the whole week like no matter what
happens even if I dro the ball the
first like I'm just not going to go on
my shower like this could be the only
opportunity I ever get like this my
dream this what I want to do I'm just
going to go out there and and be free so
and did you what I watched your um Day
on YouTube watched it last night man
incredible yeah it
was it was this is exactly what I said
before
but first touch of the ball I threw
threw an offload and I don't even know
how I threw it and maybe God was looking
down
and D's called it and called to try and
you know I said like in debuts there was
a confidence I needed like that just
that was a way like I was so
nervous you know but managed to do that
in like the first three minutes and then
you're just like like do you if that was
an intercept do you do you feel like you
would still have been in that
18-year-old Chiefs mentality where you
would have probably been subbed at 50
and had a bit of a
shocker probably probably yeah probably
be on the tools
now one pass I'm still here otherwise I
was on the to years later what a career
that pass was what a pass that was oh
that's crazy and like the week being
being in all black like the lead up yeah
um how's the how's the anxiety and like
the nerves and um building into those
games yeah it was it was like it was
crazy like it was overwhelming like
you know you probably get and this has
be always one of my most special moments
of my life but is that like ringing Mom
and Dad yeah and you know they on tears
when I told them that I've been picked
in the squad and then I've told them
that I'm starting like they just like
Bing the eyes out and I think for for
every player like to tell your mom and
dad or or someone that's a massive part
of your life like that's one of the best
moments so you get through that and then
you get 100 text messages um and then
you and granded is saying like now down
at balls this s are telling me this and
that that's funny they still they always
say when they go to the balls they get
told more about me than they know about
me um but you got to love how how much
old people frog frog be yeah um beings
yeah in BS um but yeah it was just like
a like a real awesome week like feeling
so much support and I think you know in
the ABS and always respect you know
kieren Reed for this but you know
through that week he looked after me
really well actually him malikai fika um
Aaron Smith Drome Drome
conell
like you know those guys like I looked
up to you know like those I was I can't
even believe I was chucking a seed to
them yeah or around you know around them
let alone playing with them so yeah I
was just a 20-year-old kid I was like
they're like mate you'll be right just
do your job and all those like little
messages just
like just gave me so much confidence I
like oh these guys have got my back
these guys I look up to like yeah
nothing can go wrong type feeling I just
I just had that sort of feeling to the
week that's so cool and then post that
game um obviously goes well are you
feeling comfortable in the environment
after a good performance or like what
what are you
feeling
um You probably like you feel as though
that you've earned a little bit of
respect and I think you
feel more comfortable in in the changing
room yeah and that's like walking into a
changing room as a young kid you know
being able to look at guys and being
like I did my job or you know I I played
well is is a comfort comforting feeling
um but if there's one guy that can can
make you feel uncomfortable really
quickly that's Steve
Hans and you know that's his magic
that's why he was so good yeah cuz um
you probably played a few games and and
got pretty comfortable yeah everything
was going well and you know he just P me
straight back down to earth you know
which is good yeah so he's sort of like
you you know how you said the young guys
going rolling the roller coaster they go
they get a little bit like chested out
when they're playing well and real down
in the dumpsters he's sort of the guy
who when someone would have a bad guy
would try and pump them up and when they
saw someone with their chest out like
thought they you know a little bit
better than they were he'd shoot them
down yeah yeah for sure his his ability
to to read a team and and to know his
players as you know probably you know
the best in the world um
um he knew yeah he knew when you needed
a cuddle and he knew when you need a a
kick out the ass and he could um and he
knows that every player's different yeah
so he he'd treat them how they how they
needed to be treated at the
time legend legend absolute Legend and
how are you feeling like with all the
pressure like there's a lot of pressure
being in all black you're still really
young how you feeling like well how's
your head space in in this time is this
when you started to get your anxiety and
your mental health issu sorted to come
up um it was actually it was actually
like probably like just before that yeah
um and I'm I'm comfortable to to talk
about this but three three weeks out
from my debut so end the end of the
Chief season like I just I was feeling
like pretty I was feeling real flat yeah
like my anxiety was was at a you know
all-time high um I'd like I'd been sick
I early on like I broke up with you know
as you do it 21 like girlfriend and then
had the Chief season um so I was like a
little bit rundown had all that ammen to
deal with and had a chese season
so um I was actually in a in a in a
pretty bad state post that 216 season
and true this is how like life can
change really quickly um but I went and
saw a a psychiatrist um probably yeah
four to three weeks
before my my debut and it was it was
like it was the week of I was going to
the all black camp and he prescribed me
with satel pram um 20 G and he knew what
was sort of going on um whiches like
anti-press depressants and also helps
with anxiety and he said
um you'll feel like your anxiety might
go up for the first couple days and then
in two to three weeks time you'll feel
you should start feeling really good and
it honestly couldn't have time better
because
probably that or the week before I
debuted it actually started kicking in
oh [__] and I like my anxiety went right
down um
so I don't know like it was just it was
just really good timing like seeing the
psychiatrist
um and then going into the old black
season but at the same time like my
anxiety did go down but also had the
excitement of of being an all black so
like it's it sort of like masked a lot
of what was going on yeah what does that
anxiety look like like um obviously
everyone has some form of anxiety but
like what is what do you at your Peak
anxiety look
like yeah me me at my Peak anxiety looks
like
you know and there was probably multiple
times during that Chief season um in
216 that like I honestly thought I was
going to die like you just you begin to
spin like it was with my heart so I
would get really short of breath like my
heart rate would be through the roof
jeez and like you just just couldn't
like breathe properly
um and I I had it really well like there
was a couple of
times like at training like would be
like at a Clarity walk through I just
get through that and then go
home and just go to my room and just
like wait wait it out for a couple hours
um having one of these attacks yeah
having these these panic attacks
so um you know at that at that stage I
didn't I didn't really like telling
anyone um I was getting them like before
games um and stuff like that all right
and at the at the start it was like
really
overwhelming but then you start you
start knowing like once you get get
through panic attacks and having those
feelings you still have it but you
understand that like if you wait it out
for so long like you're going to be all
right yeah um
but yeah like everyone got anxiety like
um but
obviously yeah these if you got anxiety
disorder yeah it just it's extreme like
we all worry about something but anxiety
is you know you you so for me was like
thinking about my breathing yeah be
normally bre be breathing normally and
then you just think oh no I'm not and it
just goes bang bang like just spirals
out of control so yeah what triggered it
do you know what triggered it um what
things were happening when it would
go nothing like nothing in particular
yeah but it was like I was obviously
like between 18 and 21 like i' I've R
read that roller
coaster um me as a player like I
expected so much myself always felt as
though like I was I was a lit down you
know like I was I was a check
at a young age but never felt like I was
good enough or like always wanted the
respect of others um very like critical
of my
game and then and then yeah so that that
would trigger things and I think it was
just a 2year cycle of
just like trying to train really hard
not having good thoughts in my head and
eventually you know like a 2year cycle
that just that's too much yeah so how
did you how did you get out of it you
obviously took your medication and you
made the All Blacks but um what do you
think what else helped for you to sort
of break that
cycle yeah in all honesty like it took a
2-year period because you know I said
like I talk and I actually felt real
good that week and play my debut I went
to high and I remember thinking like
it's just going to disappear like I'm
happy now yeah like it's it's gone like
of I'm an all black like everything I've
been worrying about it's going to
disappear and I remember waking up the
next day and we'd had a few beers and I
go to sleep happy hour like that's good
when remember waking up the next day and
I was like [__] like life's still pretty
[__] I'm still dealing with this yeah um
so so got through it with abs and and
medication like it's good but again it's
only like it's like it's only a plaster
like it helps but it it like it it dries
up the bleeding but there's still a lot
of stuff you got to do so that's when I
say like a 2-year
period of changing my my thought process
of you know getting into a good
lifestyle you know a two to four to even
now like you
know it it became like I got to live a
lifestyle I've got to have thoughts
um that actually really helped my
anxiety and I I still have it today but
I'm in a much better place I got a lot
more tools to manage it what are some of
those tools that you've got like yeah I
think like um being really clear um like
structuring my week yeah Lu it makes me
feel good even you know we got 2 months
off I actually uh I got a new phone got
the new phone but shout out to yeah no
this is not free this cost me an arm
League shout out to water Le podcast
comeing here get a free invo me
yeah but even you know over these last
two weeks I didn't oh our two weeks post
whe cup I didn't have a plan like I
didn't know what I was doing for two
months i' like I there's a lot of things
on yeah but I didn't have it structured
and I was actually like feeling like
anxious or like not great about it so
two days ago got my new phone and like
I've got a month and a half now of
knowing what I'm actually doing what
days I have free yeah and for me like
that that gives me like a a sense
of of you know structure to my life
organization knowing what I'm doing and
that helps my anxiety yeah um things
like like sauna yeah
um even like you know when in season um
like I'm not shy to have a beer or just
live life
like that's that's sort of my my motto
like over these two months like very
happy to be social and and go up my
friends like why not like you can't do
that for 2 months of the year yeah like
make the most of it um because when I
was at my worst I was very you got to do
this like you got to do your 30 minutes
recovery
yeah if you don't it's not going to be
good enough you got to do like it just
it gets too much like now I'm a lot a
lot Freer I'm structured but I'm not I'm
structured in a good way yeah sounds
like you've got a really good balance in
your weeks now around like having time
for yourself you love a game of golf you
got a good golf group um like you see
love a beer when when the time's right
and you it feels like you've sort of
taken that pressure off just you've put
on yourself to always feel like you had
to work out work everyone cuz you always
felt like you were never good enough but
now you feel like you probably are you
know you're good enough now and you can
sort of just um be a bit Freer with your
weeks and know that um getting away from
Rugby's just as important as training
heart yeah you're you're did right and
um and this probably like when you and
it helps like being in in good teams and
like in good environments really helps
like what Don's doing at the Chiefs is
it gives you a chance for balance it
gives you a chance to thrive and I think
the key said key you said there was like
you know when and from 18 to 20 I was
working my body and my mind into the
ground yeah like I was like well I've
got to I got to work as hard as I can
and my expectation was if you don't play
well you're not good enough and it was
just like anyone's just going
to you know anyone's just going to burn
out it was in a in a in a sense I was
burnt out yeah how would you you do that
differently if you if you went back to
the young 18year old um Anton what would
you how would you approach it
now yeah that's like you know I wish 18
year olds could have 10 years of
experience yeah and I said some this to
someone today I I just talking to my
teacher and said I'm going on a podcast
but I could say something today but in a
year time it could be slightly different
because you're always you're always
growing right um but it' just be it'll
probably be like chill out mate like you
don't have to do an all black or you
don't have to be the Superstar on day
one
like um it used to really frustrate me
like that like my passing wasn't as good
or like um I couldn't kick as good or or
whatever is like guys had been around
for eight years like I've always I was
always you know it was like me as a
young kid but I always wanted to do what
someone else done yeah and I sort of
judged myself on on what they could do
comparison comparison comparison was
like my worst enemy yeah yeah that's so
fascinating it's so cool to hear and you
did mention the Chiefs um there with
Donan um how you going up there you're
obviously a proud Chiefs man you've
played 100 over 100 games for them now
um what are the special times that stand
out for you in that Chief's Jersey or
what do they do so
well yeah there's uh there's a lot of
special times like I think in over a 10e
period um we've been on a on a roller
coaster yeah you know we've always made
the quarters semis made a couple
finals haven't won the title but um it's
through all the thick and thin um like I
just always felt like it's been a pretty
genuine family and obviously like the
multi culture is really strong up there
and
like no matter what like we've always
been close which is which has been yeah
that's probably the thing that sticks
out most like you know like from 8 years
ago or or whatever um you know your
still mates with those guys like it's a
it's a special like family environment
and I think so every team talks about
family but like some some teams actually
genuine about it yeah and yeah as you'll
know yeah probably the team that you
coach well you like you guys last year
were the form team of the competition
all the way through you had your home
final sold out um impressive it was it
was impress impressive year to watch and
then um you come to that final and
things again like you spoke about at the
Rugby World Cup 1% is just didn't go
your way and um you didn't get the
results but what do you remember from
that game obviously you as well yeah
well obviously remember running into
Dallas mccloud's head probably locking
not to get Rec carded so probably got
the rub of the green and that fact
um but yeah obviously like extremely
disappointing um especially as a as a
senior player and you've been around for
so
long and probably like the biggest you
know if I go into well if I get
opportunity to go another final again is
during the week you that sense of like
this is our time and like that's no it's
not your time you know you got to you
got to earn it but like you're like oh
like surely Crusaders can't win 7 and a
row yeah and it's been a long time for
us like obviously you do all your work
but those are real false um statements
to make in your mind and it's it's
really hard during a finals week where
there's a lot of hype to to keep your um
thoughts level yeah um you know Aaron
Walsh who's outstanding mental skills
coach um but he always always says like
try to find the the
neutral um obviously you your negative
you got your positive like and if you're
really positive that's actually that's
that's a false sense what you're feeling
if you're negative that's also a false
sense like find the neutral yeah and
reflecting on it and obviously we'
reflected on it a lot um that
probably like my biggest learning was
like
thinking like surely we can get this
done and then obviously I get yellow
carded these yellow cards and and things
are happening
and it's been a tough
year yeah [__] didn't realize a couple
of tough finals to lose like two 1%
finals yeah when you're sitting on that
um obviously they review it now the
yellow cards when you're sitting on that
um in the bin are you look watching that
big screen thinking I'm done here or
what what what was your
feeling and oh I was pretty days though
I probably lucky to um to get away with
one um but I was what I was actually
thinking and I was I had about 30 family
there oh yeah and that F from everywhere
and I was thinking jeez I hope this
yellow cut we get recard
that 20 family of flowing up from CR
from Australia all over the place yeah
and they're going to be sitting there
not watching me yeah that was my initial
thoughts and then yeah obviously just
just praying that I get to go back on
the field yeah yeah obviously you did
you prayed hard enough yeah but I could
so can so relate to your um thoughts
going into that final I feel like I was
exactly the same and I think our team
was in 2015 when we lost and then won it
the following year but that same thought
around it's our time we we deserve it we
had we finished top that same sort of
feeling but you've signed on till 2026
yeah so you got a couple more years in
New Zealand Rugby what what are your
plans like um obviously ambitious to
still continue to be an all black and um
post 2026 he he eyes on another world
cup what's where's your mind say it yeah
I love like I love being all black in
like obvious always say that you got to
earn earn the right and you absolutely
do so like I want to stick around and
obviously you got to play well and super
to to get that opportunity and that's
what I want to do over the next 3 years
and obviously by 2026 I'll know um
whether I have a good chance going to
the World Cup or not
and um I guess for me like what I always
say is that I don't want to
be around like or be wasting new rug's
money or whatever if I'm not in
contention for the all black so I think
giving myself three years to do that is
is a good amount of time obviously there
the new these new coachings these new
opinions so you don't know what what's
in store um but obviously that will
unfold in the next one two 3 years and I
feel like every position has had a
departure of certain players or but the
midfielders just seems to have just
added players like no one's left um
Quinn and the likes are going to be
backed Ellis had a big year last year
there's lots more names being added to
the group um something you've probably
prided yourself on throughout your
career is you've always had competition
for those Midfield spots and you've
always managed to fight them off and
still be selected yeah for sure
[Music]
um yeah I guess I'm competitive in that
fact but
I think you know overall like there's
nothing I love more than being named for
the all or being a part of that
environment and it's it's the love like
it's obviously you want to start but
it's the fact like being in also being
in that environment like that's um
that's what I want to do and I've still
got a lot of energy to give um and I
know there's there's a lot of
players you know these these Jordy and
and Rico who who played outstanding um
and then all the names that you've named
so there there's going to be a lot of
people competing for those positions but
what I'll say is UT in for the fight and
I've got the energy to do it oh I like
that and you're obviously good mates
with Jordi as well trying to convince
him to move back to fullback or like you
said Ric was a world class Winger trying
and get him back to the wear forap some
more Midfield spots oh no to feel like
Donnie cuz all real good mat I think he
was like maybe a little bit awkward
obviously was injured in the fact and he
might have been like oh like how's Anon
going to find this but like I've got
absolutely no crims like it's what's
what's best for the team like and they
they deserve to start they had a they
had a great world cut campaign and
that's that's not not an issue for me
like I always say like doesn't matter
the competition that you have like you
can't ask favors of people you can't ask
as to coaches you've got to earn the
right
yourself mate that is such a cool
mindset you're a lad and I'm Keen to
hear about your um Post 40 Ambitions um
this question came in as well from a few
people so I'm guessing it's pretty good
how many questions do you get you
already got some I got thousands I did
genuinely thousands you're a popular man
but what are your um post foot Ambitions
you got something lined
up
um yeah like probably like initially
would be sort of like property like try
maybe try to get into property
development oh yeah um quite interested
in in trying to do that um although I
don't know a lot about it I got a couple
mates that that Do It um so loaded as
well some of them are loaded and some of
them are not not so much loaded but
um yeah that just like sort of excites
me yeah obviously you're taking risk
yeah um um The Gambler in you the The
Gambler in me but like I
think I'm really interested in like
taking key values away from what you
install in your rugby
game and and putting it into a business
sense yeah and trying to emulate that
obviously knowing that things are
different but yeah like just working
really hard to try to get a deal done
try try to get something done and and
either you either lose all your money or
you don't
no I I wouldn't be that
silly well you you spoke about that and
you've you've already done that with
grins as well like we've obviously had
dmac and Beaver on the podcast already
how have you found your grins experience
and how's that tracking yeah thanks for
the plug um now grins is is going you're
like well I mean this this time of the
year
is is awesome you can make a can
tomorrow and sell like heat serve
alcohol over these next three months
because that's when everyone buys them
yeah but probably the best analogy is is
that you know for an
RTD it's like it's like a pub like a pub
can sell beers on Thursday Friday
Saturday which is the summer coming up
but it's actually how you get through
the Sunday to to Wednesday that you
struggle so that's why the Brand's
really important to build up so you get
through those once a month and people
are still buying your your drink so
you're not broke by the time summer
comes around again yeah um but no it's
it's been taking along really
well
um like I've got to give credit uh to
Beaver cuz he he does a heap amount of
work he's got all the um IQ of the
business yeah I couldn't tell you too
much about it other than taking photos
of D plugging on Instagram so social
media we won't get into dep but Bieber
tells me it's going well and I don't I
don't have the papers to see if it is or
not well Beav says it's going well it's
going well
100% um you're right around the
summertime of the year it's um everyone
seems to have a grins in their hand if
it's not a grins it's a space so yeah SP
summmer yeah oh good good okay H we will
get to the questions mate we got like I
said all thousands over to narrow it
down to a few but um first one is what
did Whopper do to you on your first year
at the Chiefs I'm interested to hear
this one yeah obviously I've I've seen
the questions I Chuck at this one um
it's actually your brother Tojo you
would have played this many times with
him but it um oh it's [__]
oh yeah that is a tough game man yeah
but Tojo made the the one to obviously 5
4 3 2 1 like you ended up on like two
beers if you like
yeah lost
one I was 18 years old believe it or not
I had about 38 skinnies had nothing on
me could only have you w eting more
condensed milk you need could only have
five beers before I fell over I'm pretty
sure I lost that
game all the time I I think I was at
that young kid keep calling [__] and
then everyone keep fcking on me so oh I
can't remember what I did but I was
getting obviously had a few yeah um to
fair if you if you want to Puff your
chest up you know just have a few beers
that makes you
feel I must have got smart and um
waffers ended up tying me to a tree and
leaving me there for a couple
[Music]
hours so I want to see like 2
hours obviously had a few I'm just like
sitting there tied to a tree like just
pleading them to unti me what are you
tied with a rope
rope to a tree yeah oh jeez that is good
stuff je Daisy classic Whopper though
right yeah jeez okay next one um why
haven't you gotten any better at golf in
the last 5 years probably worse and
there was a lot of comments about your
golf game yeah I bet there was
disrespecting you too yeah disrespect oh
thing is um sometimes when you're good
at something people like to hate T puppy
syndrome that syndrome they love to
knock you down I would like to
um note cuz I know Ryan coxon would have
sent plenty through he did he sent
through or four we played our hwood
today and I match play um I beat him on
the 15th hole so wow thanks for your
five comments sir coxy yeah man he sent
them before today so he'd probably be
taking all of those back right now yeah
he'd be back in his
showell um but why haven't I got B I've
pondered on this one so in the last 5
years I've probably played
let's say let's say 40 games a year so
that's 200 games gol yeah I've reckon
I've
practice I've been had about five
practice rounds or like five hours of
practice Yeah in five years over 200
rounds so as you know you're you're a
great coach what would you be telling a
player let played 200 rounds for only 5
hours 5 hours practice
how do you think you're going to get
better if you don't practice what are
you going to do are you going to start
practicing or are you even ambitious to
get better or not really no I just love
going out there smacking the ball other
thing is I'm really impatient so like I
hate slow golf um I hate practice swings
cuz I just want to hit the ball yeah
so yeah I mean I probably should go
practice but look I'm you're learning as
you're playing I'm about index 15
handicap yeah I'll go out to about a
anywhere between 15 18 depending on the
how hard the course is obviously you
play guys with a handicap like when the
handicap system is there what's the that
need I'm not there I'm not there to go
on the PGA tour I'm just here to hit a
golf on and have fun with my
M who's off the lowest handicap at the
moment out of the um all black boys
Jordy Barrett is he what's he playing
off now he' be a a one is he yeah he's
he's seriously good at yeah yeah he's um
he's one of those freakish athletes like
what is
6'4 he's fast he plays in The Backs and
he's obviously skillful yeah for him
like probably size to like speed power
skill ratio he's probably like the best
athlete you could you could come across
W the greatest athlete in the world the
goat Jordi bar he's not LeBron not
LeBron
James not not LeBron James New Zealand's
LeBron New Zealand let's just say North
Ireland and then we can extend out to
the
South yeah oh that brings up another one
would you consider yourself a North
Islander or South Islander oh now South
Islander oh yeah yeah sure well just
yeah K like yeah still home a chist
church person not a not a can or yeah I
say I'm a crush boys High student crash
Chief and high school high school old
boys yeah but you played for the North
in that Northwest South did you or yeah
yeah we we actually had um cuz a few of
us were getting vocal about it and had
quite a lengthy conversation
with fzy about how it works and how we
had to play for the north yeah which is
like I guess our first provincial rugby
side was white C
so traditionally like you should play
the north but like back in those days it
was rug the whole rugby Dynamic was way
different um but I think everyone that
had to crosscode like GE wanted to play
for the north which is like how can you
have two barretts on one team and one
bar he wanted to play for the North D
and I wanted to play for the South yeah
Neo should have played for nor like rean
it should have just been choose you know
who you're Affiliated to you can you can
choose who you're um yeah feel like
you've got the connection with the most
because yeah it was pretty weird I
remember pranking Mitch hunt about it
cuz I know he wasn't a North Islander he
played like one game for Oakland or
something and then um had to represent
the north so
yeah oh good answer okay next
one ask him about the time he got
knocked out
sparring oh yeah I I know where this
one's come from it's my my good mate
meet Patty Patrick Coley me Patty what a
l was what a l he's actually lad a name
like that yeah um we actually yeah we're
in the we had like a triple yardage and
sort of made a Wei I think it was rounds
like it was like we're just going like
minute rounds oh yeah and do feel like
meat Patty is like a bit of like a titty
beer yeah um but he's he's he's absolute
lad so he's a couple years older than me
but if you could imagine it it was like
he's quite a solid boy but I was like
young it was like butter bean versus
Floyd
Mayweather and so like but butter Bean's
like he's like facing so he's got this
back to me yeah and I'm just like
punching on the side like just going
like like a we like you know like a we
Fe the weight ver a heavy way we go and
like I haven't realized that he's like
slowly like turning around I'm just
going hard and he's just coming like hay
making and hit me straight in the face
and I don't know if you've ever had like
like concussions and rugby but like you
can like remember yeah you can sort of I
I can still remember him like his like
hand hitting me we did have gloves on
and like probably like stumbled like 4 M
backwards and just went like to the
floor true didn't get fully knocked out
I was on the floor that is brutal Pi you
off boxing or would you ever um box or
get in the ring fight for life or
anything like I'd love I'd love the
challenge I'd love the walk out but the
walk out and walk back yeah can I just
walk out and walk back maybe like walk
out like pretend to like pull you a car
now I I'd like to go to go but like I am
very unorthodox I'm quite a Gumby so I'd
find it hard I'd find it like I'm doing
like 1 2 3 4 is tough for me like
so look I'd give it a go but I'd hate to
see me swing in the I'd love to see you
have a rematch with me Patty
mate what about a what a lead Fight For
Life Fight For Life Petty
oh that' sell out for sure that this is
the next one actually who would win in
UFC fight you or Daniel that would be
another one to oh yeah and pay-per-view
gez I'd pay for this one in a cage
pounding ground well we see be a bit
quicker than
him I don't know yeah that's that's a
tough one he'd bet you bet you get your
sister to be yeah can we do that
t Team yeah yeah okay next one best
player that you've played with man and
this like this is probably why I love
being part of the All Blacks environment
because like I realize I'm not the most
talented player but man like some
players you to play with are just like
phenomenal you know like athletes and I
feel very like privileged to be to be
there and I'm not like understanding
myself like you got to work hard and I'm
good at the strengths of my game but
like I wish I could do some some things
that they do you know like could just
I'm trying like I'm gring my teeth to do
like a box jump and I just
like one I'm two leagues though one
League um but oh best best player I've
played with
um oh man
it's it's it's tough but probably
over probably over like
a long period of time cuz I've played a
lot of superb with them like as a for to
be guzzler like just phenomenal and and
as a back and I could say this a lot
about a lot of all black backs but it
would be Damen McKenzie yeah just being
on the field like for white cutle for
the Chiefs and for the All Blacks and
you you know we all see him do freakish
things watch that you know B and and
your riches and yeah re and Jordy and MK
t can do and all that you all that carry
on but just cuz I've been with him the
longest like yeah just does some
freakish things he is a freak he was um
he probably didn't especially back into
that World Cup thought he was going to
have a bit more of an involvement in it
but um yeah looking forward to
potentially getting more of The reigns
next year with Richie going so exciting
one to watch okay next one biggest one
on the punt bigest one on the punt
coming off the back of Paul eiffel's
episode yeah
yeah I actually
um I I won 4
million you said
sorry I will Paul thanks for talking out
cuz do feel like as um
competitors like there's there's not
many rugy players that don't get
addicted to Something in some way and
obviously um what I compare like punting
with is like probably a thrill that that
that is close to maybe running out or
like playing rugby yeah like picking it
on is like man that's a good thrill and
winding at home it's probably the only
thing that could be close to the thrill
we get playing rugby so that's maybe why
we we like it so much or some some
people do um but Bas um one on the punt
it's actually in
219 um and I was I was at a cafe with
with Brad Weber in Japan I was during
Bron's final week yeah and I'd done like
maybe two to three hours of reading out
about the Malin cup yeah and I read you
know there's probably like 20 different
columns everyone gives their
expertise and Val the clear like I took
a a real liking to like I just had a
feeling and I mean I've had plenty of
feelings this is probably the only time
that my good feeling come through but I
said just F
like um man I want to I want to go hard
on this horse so obviously would' been
away for a long time so we're getting
the yeah the um weekly fees but it's
probably it's not something that's going
to pull I going to blow your mind but I
put 500 each way on um Val de C paying I
think it was like 13 and fours and I the
most impressive thing about it's one was
about 200 M to go down the Flemington
straight another horse took it over so I
was like oh Manan like I'm going to get
my place so I'm going to get about
$2,000 yeah and it's just mowed it back
and it's it's one by head so I don't
know we get about 8K okay so that was um
yeah on the punt you would have been
winding that home from way back yeah and
it was quite funny cuz didn't like and I
my partner at the time like um
um she knew I was watching the Mel cup
but she didn't know how much I had on
yeah so I was like jumping up and down
but she she doesn't know that I've just
fun so then I obviously if it loss you
don't see proceeding to tell her let go
out for
dinner oh good stuff okay next one
teammate who can drink the most without
getting sloppy this guy predicted Sam
White loock
Samy wock um
okay love the love the BL but I wouldn't
put him in drinking a lot maybe cuz he
drink the least or he's a great man um
but oh the there's a a few guys in it
it's so bit annoying honestly I'd put
I'd put Tojo in there oh wow Brad
probably yourself Brad Weber gave a good
shout out too like and in terms of
someone that can enjoy a beer and and
consume quite a lot of them yeah your
brother can and I've never actually had
a drinking session with you so I don't
know he I'm just as good trust
me um so I'd say Tojo but then um like d
like d Jordy bod um like
yours
other BLS um the any other Fijian boys
they just they drink and they lose
weight yeah and that annoys me man I got
a drink and go for run those guys are
drinking and going to McDonald's just to
put it back
on the condensed milk cost started ear
man can we go
back okay two more hardest player to
tackle oh hardest player to tackle
um oh just yeah probably matu oh yeah
yeah yeah he was tough yeah and he's
obviously he's
like he's like you know like a a beast
like he'd known as a power Runner but
with his footwork but also the ability
to pass so he just yeah like to me he
was well obviously like going out
watching him and then playing against
him like he's the best midfielder to
play play the game just cuz he he had
had it all really yeah he was he's
incredible he what about um Mark T talk
to me about Mark how's he breaking so
many tackles he's he's
slipper I don't know give me some of
that give me some of that man give me
give me 10% of that oh he he's freak
just like the the numbers he gets
through in the game is just like
and saying like I think I don't know
like and we're talking about it in the
semi or maybe like it was the the third
and fourth playoffs so this Argentinian
six had the most like tackle bus for it
for a loose forward and I don't know
Samy Kane was talking about it and he
was on like 14 M and in the semi-final
MK to beats 14 players in one
game so you got to play this played
about eight we break the most for Lucy
and Mike just does it and like he just
blows out the the stats shoot like
nothing else yeah it's freakish you can
you can break a tackle okay last one
best piece of advice you have for a w Le
listener oh oh yes oh
yes got a lot up my sleeve now prob yeah
actually it's caught me off guard but
but like I I go off my gut and I was
actually talking about this
today but um and I was I'll give you the
story bit behind it but I was talking to
old teacher of mine about sort of mental
health and and things like that and he
said he's he's been like helping people
like in his family and stuff like that
which is great like we all need a good
support support network but like the
most
important like or the the best way to
make a shift in your life is for your
like yourself like internally to make a
shift
like like you can't
um you can't rely on others to to make a
difference for you like you've actually
obviously it's important to have people
around you like have a good Network and
like I'm a mental health Advocate and
it's really important to to check on
your mate um but as as a support network
you can only do so much so what I'd say
as an individual um you know like like
work on yourself and and make changes um
and if you are if you are struggling
um it is tough but the the one person
that can make it better is yourself and
it might not be tomorrow it might not be
next week but it could be in a month's
time
and it's really important when you are
struggling that or you know um yeah when
you are struggling that you work on
yourself and you get better and it's
like those those like like those habits
um that like they they Solly build up
over time M so I'm going on a massive
Tang it's so good though keep going but
it is the person that going to make the
biggest change in your life is the
person you look in the mirror so in
tough times like people are going to
help you externally you are going to
have a support network but they can only
do so much so make sure you you make the
changes you make the shifts inside
yourself and and that's how you're going
to get better I love it absolutely love
it and obviously you've been through
that so you you know better than most
and hearing you speak about it um so
powerful and so cool to hear you share
and speak so openly and honestly and
mate really appreciate you coming on the
podcast mate it's been a long time
coming but what a journey what an
absolute lad you are so um yeah all the
best with what's next for you um keep
keep going with the Grins and look
forward to your property business in a
few years and another rugby real Cy now
I'll put you on the list oh manit what a
lad what
aund $100,000 for 10 deposit we'll get
you in sign now we're we're but I
appreciate you coming on man it's been
awesome thanks hes cheers brother you're
a lead